en Ukraine depuis plus d'un an
maintenant c'est surtout la nuit que la
Russie lance ses missiles et ses drones
nous sommes ici sur une base militaire
où la défense anti-aérienne teste de
nouveaux projecteurs ils ont été offerts
par les bénévoles de l'organisation
civile ou kit qui devant la
recrudescence des attaques ont décidé
d'apporter le raid aux défenseurs du
ciel
sont importants car vers octobre une
nouvelle menace est apparue les drones
kamikaze ils ont commencé à attaquer les
villes du crâne et une solution est
apparue et dès nos forces de défense
anti-aériennes avec de la lumière c'est
une drone sont aussi détectés par les
radars mais en braquant une lumière
dessus les chances de les toucher
augmentent
depuis début de l'année 7 projecteurs
ont été fournis par allkit à différentes
brigades une aide précieuse comme le
confirme les militaire sur place
[Musique]
c'est plus efficace d'utiliser un
projecteur de cette façon la cible peut
être vue par tout un groupe sans ça on
devrait procurer des équipements de
vision nocturnes à tous nos soldats
donc ce système c'est beaucoup moins
cher
ces projecteurs ils vont être testés ce
soir à différentes distances à
différentes intensités également ils
seront optimisés afin qu'ils puissent se
repérer des drones des drones kamikazes
ainsi que des drones de surveillance et
ainsi faciliter le travail des soldats
la nuit ou ses projecteurs ont été
testés trois alertes aériennes ont
retenti dans le ciel ukrainien les
lumières d'hallkit sont plus que
bienvenus à l'heure où l'Ukraine a subi
11 attaques aériennes de grande ampleur
au cours des deux dernières semaines